the dead celebrities list is our annual
ranking of how much a celebrity although
they're now in the afterlife has earned
over the past year financially whether
it comes from their name their likeness
or their creative output even though
they're dead
these celebrities even though they're
dead they can still continue to earn
money through a variety of means if
you're someone like for example Michael
Jackson who you know features on our
list usually every year based on his
Cirque du Soleil show his Broadway show
that started this year and even from his
existing music catalog all of those
generate royalties to go to the estate
others such as Ava Bowie or Leonard
Cohen they're publishing or songwriting
or Masters have been sold so it's just
like you know Bob Dylan or Bruce
Springsteen selling off their life's
work as they did in the previous couple
of years even though these celebrities
are dead there are people working on
their behalf to facilitate these
transactions take our top earning
celebrity this year J.R.R Tolkien he's
the author of The Lord of the Rings and
The Hobbit books which are you know
beloved by millions around the world he
earned money this year through the sale
of Rights for TV film video games
merchandise board games and a variety of
other uh types of merchandising and
creative output with a Swedish video
game company called embracer that
purchased those rights back in September
and that was a purchase price that we're
hearing of 500 million dollars which is
our top earning celebrity for the year
it's interesting because the Tolkien
writes and the Lord of the Rings writes
uh break down quite complicatedly
they're owned between embracer which now
has all the rights I just mentioned
um the Tolkien estate does have uh
rights to seven and a half percent
profits of any non-derivative bookworks
Harper Collins has the publishing rights
Amazon actually has some of the rights
through their acquisition of M GM and
through their TV show that's now
streaming on Amazon Prime as well as you
know New Line Warner Brothers still have
some of the licensing rights from the
films that were made in the early 2000s
and that's a really complicated one for
this year but it also earned the most
money another celebrity who had a
record-breaking year was Elvis Presley
otherwise known as the king of rock and
roll Elvis Presley had such a
record-breaking year because of visits
to Graceland which accounted for 75
percent at least of his earnings from
this year I have from sources you know
close to the Elvis Presley estate that
once coveted restrictions lifted people
started flocking back to Graceland to
visit which was you know Elvis's home in
Memphis but in terms of the revenue or
the money that they're spending when
they're at Graceland is actually going
up it's not because of inflation which
you know again most people would think
it's because the people who run
Graceland have started offering more VIP
tier level experiences you get all these
extras you know visits with folks who
knew Elvis every time they have you know
concerts there there's also a VIP option
and it sells out every single time is
what they're telling me and you know
people are buying more merch as well as
what I'm hearing so more people are
going to Graceland not really because of
the movie you know they wanted to go
back and visit they wanted to spend
their money coveted restrictions had
lifted but the movie does have an impact
in the sense that more people are
talking about it the music is being
played more creating new interest and
bringing more people into the ecosystem
of what the Elvis Presley estate has to
offer
I think the biggest surprise this year
was Jeff Porcaro uh he's a drummer who
is most known for his work with Toto uh
he actually co-wrote the song Africa
which I'm sure you've heard at every
karaoke night you've ever been to but
that Jennifer Carroll Is Not only was he
a integral member of Toto he was a go-to
drummer for Legends like Quincy Jones
and Steely Dan he's played with a lot of
a lot of famous musicians and we're
hearing that his catalog his publishing
writes sold for 25 million dollars this
year which is you know not as high as
you know David Bowie or James Brown but
still quite stunning for someone who is
not an everyday household name like many
of the celebrities on our list
foreign
[Music]